To create a dataset, where only rows
of data exist without empty cells,
we're first going to run the workflow
with just the file brought in.
We can see empty values in the fields,
but
because there are blanks in the age and
income fields,
I suspect that these field types are not
number field types, but strings.
This is confirmed when I
click on Metadata as age and
income show up as V-strings.
So I'll first add a select tool and
change the field types for age and
income to number types.
Now when the workflow is run no values
appear in the age and income fields.
Now I can build a filter.
The filters at the records where there
are nulls in any of these fields and
remove them from the dataset.
I'll add the first filter tool and
set it to age is not null.
Then I'm going to do the same for
the other fields.
So I finish up with
homeowner is not null.
And with these four filters,
I'll be able to select out the records
where none of these fields is null.
I could've also created one filter tool
for the same operation using an or
in between the is not null
expression for each field.
In the end, we're left with five records
where there's a value in every field.